hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in his lecture what is metaphysics
Martin Heidegger is going to talk about
the human being or as he's calling it
Daza and being there literally in German
as being held out into the nothing and
this is connected with what he calls
transcendence and this is really at the
very core of the essay itself and
Heidegger's thought as a totality
particularly as it pertains to human
being and our relationship with the
totality of being and beings so what is
Heidegger talking about I'm going to
actually make it a little bit more
complicated by quoting something that he
said a little bit later on after
introducing this this theme he tells us
that the human being is actually what he
calls the lieutenant of the nothing that
is the if you think about what
lieutenant means the placeholder you
know the one who holds on to the you the
spot the one who stands in place of the
one who acts as the agent of the the
nothing and so why is this the case well
because the nothing isn't anything and
we are something we are a being within
the whole or totality of beings but we
are also a particular kind of being for
whom the other beings are disclosed and
they are disclosed because of the
nothing particularly through the what
he's calling the original mood of
anxiety so he tells us that being held
out into the nothing as design is on the
ground of concealed anxiety makes human
being a lieutenant of the nothing he
also tells us something about what he
calls our finitude that is the fact that
we are indeed finite beings we are not
the totality of being we don't encompass
the totality of being we are finite
beings we have existence in a particular
place
culture certain ways we will eventually
die we cannot do everything so he says
we are so finite we cannot even bring
ourselves originally before the nothing
through our own decision and will it's
something that gets disclosed to us so
profoundly does finitude entrench itself
in existence that our most proper and
deepest limitation refuses to yield to
our freedom now you notice that he uses
that term freedom there we are indeed
free and how is it that we have freedom
this goes back again to this being held
out into the nothing and he tells us
that is what Dawn's line means so this
is a key thing Dawn's line literally
does mean being there and it's used in
German idiomatically to also mean
existence or a thing that exists right
so being there being where well there is
a possibility within the totality of
beings because it's not as if there's
just beings all in some sort of
primordial soup or something like that
no we live in a structured existence
there's up there's down I'm in front of
the chalkboard and now it's not just
about being spatially located either I
am in front of this thing that I write
upon before the camera that is allowing
you to see me all of those are part of a
very small partly owing me who knows how
tiny right on the totality of beings and
we can move from this I can go off
camera I'm already breaking as we call
it the fourth wall right in addressing
you we can go on and on and on with
examples of this and that is something
that we do need to acknowledge it is
true it is real there's this entire
world environment er act with but
there's more what's the more nothing
more there's literally nothing outside
of the boundaries of the world there is
nothing outside of the boundaries of the
world
or nothing nothing's outside of the
boundaries of the world and so do we now
that's a little bit difficult to wrap
your head around wait wait a second
we've got this sort of you know universe
that we belong to how can we step out of
it you are right now in just even
conceptualizing how we step out of it
this is a point that not only Heidegger
made but many other people like Hegel
write once a limit is established in
place we can conceive of what lies
beyond the limit but Heidegger is saying
something a bit different here so he
says Donn's ein means being held out
into the nothing holding itself out into
the nothing he says design is in each
case already beyond beings as a whole we
transcend every single one of us we
transcend the totality of beings to
which we belong within which we have a
long history in which we are going to
keep on finding ourselves it's not as if
transcendence means going off to some
other world of beings no we sort of go
back and forth out into the nothing and
back into the world of beings and this
is a uncomfortable way to be anxiety is
one of the states that in which we
experience this so he says the being
beyond beings we call transcendence if
in the ground of its essence
he says design were not transcending
which now means if it were not in
advance holding itself out of the the
nothing it could never be related to
beings nor even to itself the fact that
we have reflexivity the fact that we can
say things about ourself like I'm doing
a good job I'm not doing a good job I
should be spending my time doing this
this is the best use of my time any of
those sorts of things where we're
reflecting upon ourself or even feeling
a mood about ourself or finding ourself
in the midst of things means that we're
already involved in transcendent and the
nothing is already there and we are
already outside to some degree of the
entire you know world of beings the
entire totality of beings and
introducing something new
every time that we do that notice we
bring something else into the world of
beings we create some new possibility
for ourselves
we do this in particularly through
action and through attitudes and through
the use of as he says our freedom and he
goes on any sense without the nothing
and being held on to nothing no cell
phone no freedom we do so always in
relation to an entire universe of beings
of which we are one particular being and
of which the nothing is not a being but
we do so through a kind of freedom that
goes beyond the world of or the totality
or the universe or the environment of
beings and allows for the introduction
of something else we don't even want to
say airily something new because that
lays too much of a stress on novelty it
could be the fact that I do the same
thing every single day all right look
let's wake up let's brush our teeth
let's wash our face let's make some
oatmeal all right do it again do it
again do it again the fact that I am
doing that already involves being held
out into the nothing even when we're
engaged in what seems like mere routine
now it you may say well that's more
within the world than being held on to
the nothing but this being held out into
the nothing is the human condition
according to Heidegger so this is
essential to understanding what it means
to be a human being it turns out that
the nothing is inescapable for any
metaphysics that will not just talk
about the totality of beings other than
human being but the human place within
and in relation to the other beings so
how do we how do we do this by relating
ourselves to beings and beings by what
he calls me latest behavior refusals
criticisms negations all of those things
that introduce distinctions within the
whole of being
even negating in the sense of saying
look this book is is Heidegger and not
Hegel it doesn't seem very negative but
it already that that act of
distinguishing that is involved in human
you know communication already is nihill
ative behavior and we do that on the
basis of the nothing and being held out
into the nothing so this is really quite
a brilliant thing to point out that in
every action every decision every
ratification every choice to go back to
routine we are being held out into the
nothing and transcending beings as a
whole and introducing our own
contribution as what he calls the
lieutenant of the nothing this is what
Heidegger sees as at the core of human
being and this is what metaphysics as a
type of transcending involves
you